welcome everyone I'm Steven a business
development manager on Google Play along
with my colleague Brian we hope to
recall you with some tools and tips for
growing and engaging users on Google
Play Google Play gives you access to a
massive use of 1 billion potential users
your challenge as a developer is to the
right users use their feedback to
improve your app and engage them in the
long run we're going to walk you through
some tools that Google Play offers to
make this easy we've parted out some of
the topics here I'm going to cover store
listings and experiments Brian will then
cover interactions with users
translation alpha beta testing as well
as developer pages we have some cool
giveaways for you as well so before I
begin I wanted to share with you that
formerly I was a naval officer on a
nuclear submarine and actually see some
parallels between life on a submarine
and the store listing that I like to
share with you so icons icons or
everywhere my submarine for example in
itself was an icon represented strength
and deterrence you should be asking
yourself what is your icon say about
your app or game it's the first thing
people see it doesn't matter how great
your app or game is if no one downloads
it an effective app icon app or game
icon serves as a quick identifier for
your app you should also think about
changing it up seasonally or perhaps
around holiday specials next is your
title it's also one of the first things
people see I can refer to my old
submarine as the USS West Virginia ssbn
736 gold group 10 or I can just refer to
as 736 gold which is what most people
called it similarly with your app you
want to keep it short and
we does anyone see the play on words in
this game's title you want to be
thoughtful about your brand and
anticipate the future for example how
will a version to look next our
descriptions you can imagine on the
submarine descriptions are everywhere
but the last thing you wanted to do is
go into a radiation zone without wearing
your thermal luminescent dosimeter in
your app you want your description to be
short and you want to use bullets to
highlight your product offering and tell
the user what your act what your app or
game actually does this is also a great
place to talk about what's new on a
submarine you can imagine day in and day
out you get bored with the same food
eating the same thing 100 days in a row
but on occasion we would hear that
there's some new food coming and we all
get excited right and I distinctly
remember one year sort of floating
around at 400 feet below the surface we
actually had turkey on Thanksgiving
believe it or not so that was cool we're
excited about what was new similarly
with your with your Play Store listing
you could talk about a potential you I
redesign or now that you may be
supporting we're so this brings us to
store listing experiments this allows
you to test different parts of your
store listing page there are several
things you can test your icon your
feature graphic screenshots a
promotional video and your description
all to see how these assets may improve
your conversion rate in summary we
tested various approaches experiment a
could have been approaching a target
from beneath whereas experiment be could
have been approaching a target from
behind through the baffles we would then
take that data and decide what's the
best way to approach our targets going
forward based on their attributes
similarly with store listing experiments
you can use data instead of intuition to
optimize and texting graphics of your
store listing
so you want to start with testing icons
icons can have the greatest impact
either positive or negative on your
installs test early second you want to
have a question in mind when you're
testing one having an objective for
example this artwork visualizing
gameplay drive more installs and artwork
that doesn't so best practices
developers have been asking us for best
practices we'd like to share with you
some things that we think it helped or
that you should consider when running
your experiments so first as I mentioned
before conduct you know start with a
hypothesis then you want to test it you
want to test one thing at a time you
want to iterate you want to do the test
long enough to get statistical
significance you don't want to you don't
want to cut the test off too short and
then of course you want to pay attention
to the banner in the dev console which
gives you your results probably most
importantly you want to be bold minor
little adjustments probably will be
inconclusive so baked big broad changes
and test those to walk you through few
examples here for some successful game
developers who use store listing
experiments for example congregate test
a different icon art and they saw
ninety-one percent increase in installs
just by testing the icon as you can see
rovio use three rounds of testing until
they found the optimal winner this knave
taken them a little bit longer but it
was completely worth the investment as
they're able to iterate incorporate
their learnings and actually saw a
pretty good boost does anyone see which
icon which variant of which experiment
is the winner
alright
in contrast here's an experiment
conducted on screenshots dots a game
developer the user to very use a very
measured and controlled approach and
testing their screenshots so they held
everything constant except the
illustration of the gameplay mechanics
and they also had a great result that's
all for store listings and experiments I
like to thank you and turn things over
to lieutenant Brian Brian will take the
helm and bubble you up through the
surface thanks Steven so now that you've
tested your store listing page to see
what resonates best with your sailors
your submarine is shipshape and ready to
launch so the next step is to interact
with your crew through the ratings and
reviews section of the developer console
it's one of the most important aspects
of the Play Store and it's incredibly
easy for you the developer to do so
ratings are one of the top ways that
users will market your app to other
people they're also going to help you
understand what users love and hate
about your app and how their sentiment
has changed over time replying to
reviews is one of the best ways to
create meaningful connections with your
users and show them that you listen to
their feedback to improve your product
now we've listened to you developers
feedback and added some features that
you wanted most within the developer
console so the ratings chart that you
see is now available on the reviews page
making it easy to track trends in
individual star ratings and you can also
search for specific reviews and do a
free text search across all of your
reviews recently launched to one of the
most requested features being able to
get a notification once a user updates a
review that you've responded to now
ratings can materially impact your
installs so you want to work towards
improving your scores so that you could
even be
moded by google play we have a minimum
bar of four point 0 for inclusion in any
of our merchandising opportunities we
encourage everyone to get into a
dialogue with your users replying to
both good and bad reviews it'll make
sure there's not a mutiny on your store
page so here's an example from one of my
developers Zombo droid if you ever need
an awesome app to make memes i suggest
you check them out but you can see how
they're actively responding to low
reviews and asking the user to email
them at their support address this
serves a few purposes first it's going
to help increase engagement second it
looks much better to users who have not
yet downloaded the app to show that the
developer is willing and able to respond
to technical questions and support them
and again after you've worked with the
user on their issue going back and
asking them to update their review can
result in an increase in your ratings
and higher stars so as the song goes in
the Navy you can sail the seven seas
well if we're doing all of that
traveling we also need to make sure that
we're going to be speaking the right
language for the country whose port that
we're in let's continue our focus on the
user with a little different twist
making sure that they can effectively
interact with your Play Store listing
and app because it's in their language
so within the developer console you
already have access to a number of
optimization tips and recommendations
and these now include localization and
internationalization options to help you
take your app global you can see these
recommendations bubbled up within the to
do section under optimization tips here
you can see the recommendations to
translate our store listing make the
screenshots and videos reflect our
target apk language and translate the
actual strings within our app
so you can easily translate your Play
Store listing page either by providing
your own translation text or purchasing
professional translations directly from
the developer console if you don't
provide translation text for your store
listing Google Play will either show an
automated translation or the default
language setting for your application
but neither of these is ideal if your
users have a local language preference
in addition to your Play Store listing
page you'll also want to make sure that
your apk itself is translated into other
languages fortunately Google makes this
extremely easy as well using the app
translation service you can easily
purchase professional translations for
your apk strings and in-app items as
well to find this option in the Google
Play Developer console you'll want to
sign in and select a nap and then click
on APK on the left side at the bottom by
this apk translation service option you
can click start or check progress to
launch the Google Play translation
manager after you've selected the
language that you want to translate your
app or the strings into you can browse a
list of third-party vendors who are
pre-qualified by Google to offer
high-quality translations you can upload
the strings that you want select the
destination or target language and then
choose your translation vendor based on
time and price you can see the estimates
that are given in the Google Play
Developer console for each of these
third-party options once you've
purchased translations you'll receive an
email from your vendor and can then
interact directly with them to work on
your translations once you've added
translations to your apps text strings
you can upload the translated apk file
to Google Play and translated versions
will be available to users whose
language preference matches the
translation languages
you added if you stop by later I
actually have hundred dollar translation
service coupons that you can pick up at
the tables over here after filling out
either our developer profile or review
of this session so now you should have a
pretty solid Play Store listing right
we've talked about best practices for
your icon title description and then
using store listing experiments to
optimize each of those for your users
and then we've even localized our APK to
make sure that the language being
displayed on the store listing and in
the app itself is right for our users I
want to back up a second though and talk
about strategies that you can use when
actually developing your app in the
first place Google Play is a great tool
called alpha and beta testing that can
help you prototype iterate test and
launch your app alpha and beta testing
is configured directly in the developer
console you have the ability to upload
the apk and distribute it before
releasing to the public users always
have to opt in to this functionality and
can never leave reviews and of course
google loves data so you'll have access
to a wide range of statistics and
information about the alpha and beta
configurations to help you troubleshoot
and fix issues there are two ways to
share your alpha and beta builds open or
closed closed alpha or beta testing is
invite only and manage through google
groups this means you'll need to add
email addresses to a group and then your
users will have access to download the
alpha and beta builds you can also have
an open beta which includes a custom URL
that anyone can join and opt into the
developer can set a maximum number of
testers and the overall progression
might be a closed beta test to an open
beta test and then actually distributing
that custom URL via social media to your
biggest fans to get them early access
and get them testing out your new app
a number of top developers have seen
great success with alpha and beta
testing to ensure that new releases are
bug free and successful so now that you
know how to launch a great app the last
topic I wanted to touch on today is a
new easy way to promote your brand on
google play called developer pages think
of this as the nose art on the plains of
our aircraft carrier it's going to get
you attention and your users are going
to love it so right now if you click on
a developers name in google play you're
taken to a rather bland page that lists
all of the developers apps now you
actually have the ability to transform
that space into a unique page on Google
Play to promote your entire app catalog
with these developer pages you're able
to upload graphics explain what your
company is all about and pick a special
app to feature at the top this gives you
a single destination to promote all of
your apps on Google Play and many of our
top partners have already created their
developer pages check out any do they
have a graphic banner at the top the
description of the company and the
options that they offer and then a
featured app at the top of the screen as
well and we know that you guys are
building for mobile tablet wear and TV
but developer pages look great on
desktop too so you can link to them from
your apps web site you're oh it's your
own personal branded page on Google this
is one of my developers II do they have
an awesome graphic at the top it's an
eye-catching description and again that
featured app on their developer page as
well has anyone here created a developer
page up to three for you guys right not
yet soon so Steven and I have done a lot
of talking so far and I was hoping to do
something interactive here where we
could actually build a developer page
together I don't know if you guys have
your laptop's with you is that something
maybe we'd be interested in maybe
it's thinking about it all right I'll
run through the steps if you guys want
to follow along with a real quick we can
do that too it's so easy let's take a
couple minutes if you have some graphics
and tools ready for you so at the top of
the screen we're just going to sign into
the Google Play Developer console and
click on developer pages on the left and
then we want to enter some of the
information that we're going to have
about our Google Play Store listing so
promotional text 140 characters to
describe the brand not to be confused
with a tweet you can even add
translations of that as well website
this should point to your company
website or a website that's associated
with one of the top apps maybe the app
that you're going to feature throw in
some graphic assets so a developer icon
that's going to be in the circle at the
top of the page and a header image this
header image is going to be used not
just on desktop but that big screen
space at the top but also on mobile for
you know the recommended app section
it's going to have the graphic taking up
the full space across the screen and
then the featured app so play will
auto-populate all the different apps you
have in that developer account and you
can select one to pin at the top so if
you're having a special if you have a
seasonal item or something that you just
want to promote a little more you can
click that featured app right there to
sort of pin it to the top I'll give you
guys a couple minutes if you're if
you're clicking through any of them
I was hoping to even show off one or two
awesome ones but I'm thinking guys are
still working so maybe we can maybe we
can sort of huddle over there later and
we can look at some guys developer pages
I want to thank everyone for come to the
session couple quick items that we can
wrap up with because I know Stephen and
I have been talking a lot but we do want
to talk with all you guys individually
too and I think with a group this size
we can probably head over to the tables
in the back and maybe chat with you guys
one on one if you have any specific
questions or issues with google play a
couple of things I'd love for you to do
to help me out so at the top right there
that's a quick survey to tell me about
this session did you like the topics we
covered store listing beta testing
developer pages did you find it helpful
and then number two and i love this one
because i got a custom URL with that big
Android BBQ at the end but I want you to
fill out a developer profile this is
going to go directly to Stephen and I
and if you have any questions issues
need some help with Google Play
strategies or tips let me know in that
form and we're going to be able to
respond to you we also have a great book
secrets to app success on google play
this is written by google contains lots
of juicy information about your Play
Store listing and you fill out those two
forms for me I'd love to send you off
with one today so with that I'm going to
wrap up but again it'd be great to talk
to everyone later over here thanks a lot